et puis un autre problème c'est que les
gens deviennent très méchants ils sont
en demande tout le temps la dissolution
d'oasis à paris c'est le manque il était
une pouvait plus souvent la dissolution
croyais que c'étaient les frères
gallagher gallagher et qui en fait ne se
pouvait plus se voir et en fait c'était
lié à la drogue c'était lié à ça
maintenant elles m'ont alors plus les
réactions des maisons je savais pouvoir
l'arrêter joué 10 lucernois se répandent
en préservant la question l'érection des
maisons de disques elles sont très
cotonneuse parce que les maisons disent
le dit ce mec il a vendu 10 millions
d'albums on va pas le l'engueuler s'il a
envie de se détruire nous on vend des
disques c'est tout bêtement amy
winehouse quant à la destruction au
ralenti pendant deux ans tout le monde
savait ce qui allait se passer il y
avait on ne pouvait rien faire elle
avait vendu 20 millions d'albums avec 40
millions d'euros en banque qu'est-ce que
vous qu'est ce que son père chauffeur de
taxi allé lui dire elle avérée selon
tous les critères la veille on la laisse
justement vont vous avez vous on vous a
pas laissé vous détruire et deux femmes
qui sont très importantes dans votre les
vies et dans votre livre la première
c'est virginie despentes vous dit en
gros que c'est grâce à elle que vous
avez arrêté tout ah là là elle me
regarde
et des pentes in immense écrivain et
auteur va trouver qui est voilée on vous
essayez d'être ensemble on avait cette
envie et on s'est dit on va se
désintoxiquer on va tout arrêter parce
que ce qu'il faut savoir un couple qui
essaye de se désintoxiquer c'est raté
tout public ça peut pas y en a toujours
un qui rentrent le soir en disant chéri
j'ai rencontré bacha on va faire une
petite un petit accroc au contrat et
boum ça repart pour eux donc nous s'est
désintoxiquée et de l'alcool et de la
drogue parce qu'on avait moi j'avais un
gros gros problème d'alcool parce que la
force de prendre des substances alors on
arrondit avec le jack daniel's pardon je
devrais pas cité les noms mais
alors je vais vous dire quelque chose
philippe vraiment je trouve absolument
merveilleux que vous racontiez tout ça
parce que vous le dites avec vraiment
beaucoup de franchise groupe ont coûté
beaucoup de sincérité en même temps dans
le livre vous expliquez aussi à quel
point c'est une descente aux enfers
parce qu'il ya la période festive que
vous avez aidé inquiets d'un an et
quelques et après ce n'est que du manque
que de l'enfer voilà que de la
destruction de la côte que de l'eau
redescend de la méchanceté gratuite va
voir et donc arrêtez ça a été fabuleux
formidable et merci virginie dont on
sait bien aidé l'un l'autre on a tenu et
laurent et alors ça c'est très beau à ce
couple qui renaît ensemble et en même
temps il ya aussi un autre personnage
féminin dans votre livre est extrêmement
important c'est votre fille ah bah oui
puis oui puis ma fille bien sûr vous
raconter le jour où vous où justement
vous découvrez que votre ci prend de la
cocaïne voilà at moi je me disais je
voilà très bêtement je me disais bon moi
j'en ai marre et donc ça s'est réglé
dans la famille donc mes enfants
n'auront pas besoin d'en prendre et un
jour je rentre de tourner la nouvelle
star et elle avait laissé plein de
journaux sur la poubelle qu'elle ne
voulait plus lire et donc moi papivore
je me précipite pour voir ce qu'elle
jetait s'il y avait pas un jour dell que
j'avais pas lu et tombe la fameuse pie
rouge jaune blanche à la main spy pardon
mais on connaît pas la fameuse pareil
alors il a fabriqué les toxicos adoré
aller chez mcdo prendra paille joueurs
blancs regarde il dit ne les ai pas eus
mcdo ou herbes etc et quand j'ai vu ça
là j'ai vu j'ai eu la pression que je me
se faisait renverser par un bus quoi
c'était donc j'ai poussé un hurlement
j'étais tout seul dans l'appartement à
déculpabiliser ben non vous êtes ma vie
c'est moi qui peut-être et donner les
vidéos je me suis dis donc la race
humaine n'a jamais rien approuveront des
condamnés à tout recommencer et je me
suis rendu compte qu'en fait c'était un
chemin pas personnel que chacun devait
mener quoi tout ce qu'on était tout seul
en fait et puis moi alors je me suis dit
je vais le l'ongle et puis je me suis
dit mais toi personne tant connu qui
situera qu'est ce que tu vas faire là
dessus mais on n'avait rien dit vous
n'allez pas vous avez aimé plus en toile
a quant à elle quand elle est revenue ce
soir là je me suis dit cette petite
ville entourée de double d'affection
j'ai été un papa qui faisait qui
pourrait par monts et par vaux il avait
on va aller au concert ensemble qu'est
ce que tu veux aller voir la fiche
thyssen ce qui passe à bercy on y va
j'étais avec quelle joie et bien qu'il
se disait pourquoi il est tout en les
adaptant à me coller sa vie est ce que
vous avez découvert mois n'avait jamais
parlé ensemble on n'a jamais parlé
jusqu'à il ya quelques jours car il ya
quelques semaines j'étais en train de
terminer
il m'a dit tu sais j'ai tout arrêté
l'alcool et la drogue j'ai fait comme
toi j'ai tout arrêté et je me suis dis
donc ça y est merci d'un veau et l'ami
comme tout le monde s est comme dit un
moment lou reed il dit il c'est un
circuit de 10 ans faucon terry d'un
célèbre chanteur lou reed dans
l'oreillette qui avait fondé le velvet
underground toutes les chansons les
chansons sur la drogue et lui disait
c'est un circuit un cycle disant et si
tu prends de l'héroïne tu as beaucoup de
chance de mourir avant
on